sharing startup rework has announced
that it will lay off 2400 employees with
close to half of the fifth of its Global
Workforce rather we work along with its
charismatic founder and former CEO Adam
Newman the company was one of the
hottest startups in history then it
plunged from nearly 50 billion dollars
in value to basically worthless in just
six weeks we've studied the most money
losing companies that have gone public
that have the most that have lost money
12 months before they've done their IPOs
weworks the second most money losing IPO
after Uber remember this guy Adam Newman
the charismatic founder of wework the
gala Hut we worked into a 47 billion
unicorn startup and then to near
bankruptcy in just six weeks who became
a billionaire in the process by getting
paid 1.7 billion dollars just to leave
the company he is like and that's a guy
who knows he built a sinking ship on
bolt so he's trying to get all his money
out and then it sold 700 million that
they are supposed to go public right he
was just then they paid him not to work
basically to resign and he got that like
they paid him basically they paid him a
premium on his shares to get him to go
away yeah that guy is back and he's
coming back with a vengeance he's got a
new startup he wants to buy into called
flow and guess what this disgrace
founder already got 350 million dollars
thrown at him for this new startup
making his new company already worth a
billion dollars even though they have
zero working product yet now on the
outside this may seem unfair Adam Newman
did some really unethical stuff at
wework he hyped up the valuation he ran
we worked like a cult with him as the
charismatic cult leader while doing
sketchy things like trademarking the
word we in his name and then selling it
back to the company for six million
dollars while pocketing hundreds of
millions of dollars in Consulting fees
that he offered to rework investors on
the down low so why should this guy get
a second chance why should this guy get
350 million dollars thrown at him when
the average person can barely even get a
raise because the reality is this is
exactly how Silicon Valley works if
you're a venture capitalist who are you
gonna invest in a brand new 18 year old
founder who has zero experience or Adam
Newman who understands how the game
works who understands is that in order
to make money in the startup World in
order to IPO and go public you have to
be really good at hyping up something
from nothing a co-working company no
this is a revolutionary tech company
that's building the future of work a
boring residential real estate company
no this is flow a revolutionary real
estate startup that's gonna change the
way we live forever float is gonna bring
us to Utopia Adam Newman is going to
bring us to Utopia but will he
this is Adam Nina's second act
[Music]
foreign
Newman and his investors may be ready to
dive into flow but they first have to
deal with the horrible Market we're in
right now where everyone is afraid of a
recession and thus after the stock
market just wrapped up its worst year
since the 2008 crisis but despite the
Bloodshed in the markets our longtime
partner Masterworks the art investing
platform has been helping investors just
like you see Real Results paying out
tens of millions of dollars in total in
2022 alone not the faceless investors
mind you but to viewers just like you
but if you missed out it's not too late
Masterworks has pulled off three sales
just in the last 60 days alone which
returned 10 13 and 35 Nets Yes you heard
that right 35 returns try finding that
level of performance anywhere else it's
no wonder why Outlets like CNBC are
raving about Masterworks and as AJ
tranviewer if you're ready to invest
anywhere from 10 to 25 000 right now
pause the video scroll down and click
the link below to skip the wait list now
pause the video and click the link below
now thanks to Masterworks for sponsoring
this video
after the wework Fallout Adam Newman and
his family kind of fell Into Obscurity
most people assumed that they went back
to Israel where they're originally from
he part that they were selling some of
their properties in the Hamptons but
remember Anu Newman got 1.7 billion
dollars from leaving wework and a guy
that's neurotic as Newman isn't just
gonna retire and sit on the beach no no
no so while he waited for the heat to
die down on him while he waited for the
public to stop wanting to Lynch him he
was making big moves in the background
and he was pouring a lot of that money
into real estates by 2022 Adam and his
wife have bought up over 90 million
dollars worth of residential real estate
all around America they were buying up
entire apartment blocks and they were
doing all of this on the down low on the
outside it looked like this wework guy
was just investing in residential real
estate as any billionaire would do no
one thought for a second that a guy
would as bad of a reputation as Adam
would ever try to get into the startup
world again but behind closed doors that
was exactly what he was preparing for
Adam Newman Was preparing for something
big he was preparing for his comeback
you know people are wondering why he's
able to raise money and what I always
tell Founders is when you see these like
weird funding and you can't get your
heads around them it's typically has to
do with track record and credible
audacity trumps prior blunders so say
what you will about Adam Newman he is
audacious and he has credibility people
forget his origin story they only
[Music]
mid-2020 it was less than a year after
Adam's downfall and yet he was already
secretly back on the startup scene but
instead of playing the role of the
charismatic founder this time he played
the role of the charismatic Tech
investor and he became one of the main
investors in a startup called Alfred
basically Alfred was like a delivery
after apartment tenants but instead of
ordering food you could order concierge
services like laundry groceries pet care
and cleaning Marcellus apone and Jessica
Beck co-founded Alfred while at Harvard
Business School back in 2014. at first
Alfred was nothing more than a way to
easily order services that most renters
needed for their Apartments but as the
company grew Marcella and Jessica saw
the potential in 2019 they bought out
Bixby a rental building management
company which meant they had officially
entered the big leagues now they weren't
just offering concierge services to
renters but they were also offering
Property Management Services to
landlords and that's when Adam Newman
jumped at the opportunity to get in on
the disruption of residential real
estate in 2020 he invested 30 million
dollars into Alfred and became the
company's biggest shareholder and sure
the move may have made people scratch
their heads a bit Adam Newman was always
the kind of guy to start new businesses
not invest in them but for almost two
years it seemed like he had maybe
accepted his new place in the world
maybe Adam had really changed but of
course none of that was true somewhere
along the line Adam sat back he looked
at Alfred's business model and thought
hey why don't I do this myself Alfred
had just the right amount of innovation
and disruption for Adam's taste he could
just imagine the possibilities Tech
entrepreneur makes ways in residential
real estate the future of work no this
was the future of living yes he could
see it now if he could take the idea
behind Alfred but do it at a much bigger
scale while using all the tricks and
lessons he learned from rework this
really could be his second coming Adam
already had a lot of properties in his
Investment Portfolio so if he went into
this he wouldn't have to work with
landlords like Alfred didn't but instead
he would be the landlord himself if it
was perfect all he had to do was borrow
Alfred's business model switch up a few
core strategies and he would be sitting
on a gold mine so in 2021 Adam bought a
Carson living one of Alfred's biggest
competitors if he was gonna make the
idea behind Alfred his own he would need
someone with a know-how to make it
happen and who better than the founder
of Alfred's main competitor from there
he needed more Apartments So Adam
started quietly buying up more than a
billion dollars worth of apartments with
most of those purchases happening all
within the last year quote entities tied
to Mr Newman have been quietly acquiring
majority stakes in more than 4 000
Apartments valid at more than a billion
dollars in Miami Atlanta Nashville Fort
Lauderdale and other U.S cities and once
every last piece of his plan had fallen
into place Anu revealed his newest
brainchild to the world flow Adam's
secretive new startup that is probably
going to be wework before Apartments
instead of offices Flo has no working
product right now and they're keeping
everything under wraps and yet Adam
Newman's due startup is already worth a
billion dollars
[Music]
in August 2022 Andreessen Horowitz or
a16z one of the biggest Venture Capital
firms out there posted this article
investing in flow quote our nation has a
housing crisis our country is creating
households faster than we're building
houses structural shortages and
available homes for sale push housing
prices higher while young people are
staying single for longer and
increasingly concentrating and highly
desirable Urban centers these factors
put enormous pressure on rents in the
nation's most dynamic cities starkly
revealing the troubling realities of
both sides of the housing markets 2
historical models the first model is you
own a home you call your own typically
with a multi-decade mortgage near your
employer if you can find a house as
these locations aren't often building
new housing if you can afford the house
as housing prices in many such places
have skyrocketed and even then you're
now stuck you can't move even if your
Economic Opportunity or life path wants
to take you somewhere else the second
model is you rent an apartment by
renting under apartment is a soulless
experience do you even meet your
neighbors much less have any friends in
your complex does it feel like home or
just a place to sleep are you proud to
bring your friends and family to visit
or hesitance and you end up paying rent
for decades and still own zero Equity
nothing Apartments don't create any bond
between person and place and without a
community it also doesn't create a bond
between person to person now drop the
impact of the post-covet world into this
where many people are now working
remotely without much face-to-face
interaction and you're left with a lot
of problems in today's residential real
estate the residential real estate world
needs to address these changing Dynamics
and yet virtually no aspect of the
modern housing market is ready for these
changes which is why we're excited to
partner with Adam Newman and his
colleagues on Flow which is a direct
strike on precisely this problem Adam is
a Visionary leader who revolutionized
the second largest asset class in the
world commercial real estate by bringing
community and brand to an industry in
which neither existed before Adam and
the story of wework have been exhausted
chronicalize analyzed and fictionalized
sometimes accurately and for all the
energy put into covering the story it's
often underappreciated that only one
person has fundamentally redesigned the
office experience and led a paradigm
changing global company in the process
Adam Newman we think it is natural that
for his first Venture since wework Adam
returns to the theme of connecting
people through transforming their
physical spaces and building communities
where people spend the most time their
homes residential real estate the
world's largest asset class is ready for
exactly this change shelter is one of
our most basic needs in a world where
limited access to home ownership
continues to be a driving force between
inequality and anxiety giving renters a
sense of security community and genuine
ownership has a transformative power for
our society make no mistake this kind of
mission is a heavy lift we are thrilled
by the scope and aspiration of this
project it is not lacking in Vision or
ambition but only projects with such
lofty goals have a chance at changing
the world and
and when you put it like that it starts
to sound pretty appealing man maybe this
will change the world you start to see
why a16z dumped 350 million dollars into
this bet the biggest single bet they've
ever made which makes flow worth over a
billion dollars before it even launched
I think it's a real positive friend
reason it's like look yeah I do you know
you you just raised a ton of money I
think their business model works by
taking as much oxygen in the room as
possible which means to be actively
fundraising always that's it's tied it's
true of Blackstone it's true of Apollo
it's true of Carlisle it's true of KKR
any of these publicly traded
investment managers
they live and die by their ability to
constantly be raising funds which
implicitly means you have to constantly
be writing funds but then again this is
exactly what Founders and Venture
capitalists are best at they need to
sell you on how this is the future they
need to paint a picture of Utopia
because that's how they make money even
if the majority of these startups
business models fundamentally will never
work to this day wework still does not
make a single sense none of that matters
because if by the time the startup does
crash and burn the VCS would have
already collected their management fee
and Founders like Anna Newman are able
to cash out in other ways like his 1.7
billion dollar Severance and recent wins
by showing that Adam Newman goes and
picks him and recent wins because they
have the ability to write a 350 million
dollar check and recent wins because
they have 350 million dollars less that
they have to actually put into the hands
of other entrepreneurs now they can do
it with just one check so it's a
multi-faceted win for them and it's a
multi-faceted win for Newman and that is
what most people don't stand about Adam
Newman Adam Newman is not some evil
froster that the world should hate all
he did was realize how the game is
played and decided to be the best player
out there
before the world of venture capitalists
and modern day Bankers there was one
baking family that ruled them all the
Rothschilds and the actual story behind
The Rush house is insane born in an old
Jewish ghetto the rosh house arrested
become the World's First International
Bank lending money to Kings governments
and nobility they were notorious for
funding both sides of Wars to ensure
that they would always profit leading
one Economist at the time to say quote
there is but one power in Europe and
that is Rothschild End quotes but the
problem is the Rothschilds are extremely
secretive to this day which has led them
to be shrouded in conspiracy theories
it's hard to tell what's real and not
but I wanted to set out to find out the
truth to find out the truth about the
Rothschilds because like them or hate
them there's gotta be something you can
learn from the world's most powerful
baking Dynasty and I put all this
Research into our new private
documentary on the Rothschilds that you
can watch right now by clicking the card
on the screen click the card on the
screen to watch now
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]